umgangsformen 4.0 tipps von professor
thomas schäfer elmayer heute begrüßung
und vorstellung grüßen ist eine ganz
wichtige situation wo wir auch in der
lage sind die stimmung zu beeinflussen
durch unseren ton durch unsere mimik
durch unsere freundlichen
gesichtsausdruck eben und auch durch
unsere wortwahl und wir sollten diese
chance nutzen besser zehn mal zu viel
als einmal zu wenig zu grüßen
beim vorstellen gilt bei uns die regel
dass die rang
tiefere person der reinhören person
vorgestellt wird neu erzählt und leuten
vor über 100 jahren kontakt es kann im
beruf zählt da natürlich die position
einer person in der gesellschaft ist in
unserer kultur die dame im rang höher
als daher
und wenn man vorstellt dann fragt man
die ranghöhere person darf ich ihnen
vorstellen und nahmen titel und
möglichst auch noch eine
zusatzinformation wird dann auch es
leichter anschließend wieder ein
gespräch zu führen